round six of the US and US women's chess  championships here in st. Louis it was  the day before the rest day and the top  players in the country gave it their all  in a bid to make a move of the  leaderboard in a battle of co-leaders  Perugino Cobian won upon against sam  Shanklin but in time pressure the tie  turned quickly and Shanklin was able to  pocket the win to find himself the  surprise leader atop the standing even  more unexpected was the result of  15-year old anyway whose win against  Dorsett Eric Shawnee has her in clear  first place  against a field filled with five past  champions the players are recharged and  ready in a race to the finish round  seven action starts right now